2020 is coming to an end and now it's
that time for us here at gamespot to
decide what we think
are the 10 best games of the year it is
never easy but please know we put a lot
of thought
care and consideration into this whole
thing so before we get started
make sure to hit the subscribe button so
you can stay up to date for everything
that's happening in the future
and beyond without further ado here are
the 10 best games of the year
as told by the very passionate people
who love them so
[Music]
animal crossing new horizons is
different and i totally didn't expect it
to evolve what i already loved about
animal crossing so much it has all of
those animal crossing touch points
you talk to your villagers every day the
store changes every day the seasons
change
but new horizons added layers of
mechanics that
at first i was nervous about like
crafting and resource gathering
but they actually complement that
gameplay loop so perfectly that i was
really
pleasantly surprised i think my 900
hours are a testament to that but even
more so i think nintendo really
understands that animal crossing is a
lifestyle
and has really leaned into that ongoing
game experience this year
in ways that i could not have foreseen
when i reviewed the game in march
being able to see those announcements to
wake up and see this is what's coming in
december
has given new life to the game that i
didn't have with something like newly
for even wild world which i played every
day for two years
in conclusion um please help me i
can't stop playing but that's the beauty
of it
that's why animal crossing new horizons
is one of the best games of 2020.
[Music]
half-life has established itself as a
franchise that innovates the medium with
each
installment so the very idea of bringing
back a seemingly
dead game after 13 years in any capacity
is a hugely daunting task and
with half-life alex valve has certainly
delivered this game isn't just a eureka
moment for vr games but in its own
merits is one of the best pc games
ever made it takes the symbiotic
immersive vr experience
and seamlessly interweaves it with
vale's masterclass game design
world building and storytelling from
alex as a character
to the gravity gloves to even
dismantling everything you think you
know
about loading a gun in a game half-life
alex is holistic
and proving that you can have compelling
narrative-driven games
in vr something that i thought was a
fleeting gimmick in games but i am
confident now
is here to stay it accomplishes all of
this by tossing you into moments of
sheer
horror brain warping puzzles and teeth
grinding gun fights and does so
with flawless pacing and it's all
bookended
with an ending that well let's just say
it does a little more than set the path
for half-life's future
alex on all fronts is a stroke of
brilliance that has completely warped my
view of vr games and even possibly games
going forward so yeah it is well
deserving to be among
gamespot's best of the year
[Music]
this is truly an unjust game your
chances of winning are almost
none but if my voice is reaching you
there may yet be a possibility open to
you
[Music]
we are going to make you understand one
must take
full responsibility for their actions
persona 5 in and of itself
is already an amazing game it's got an
amazing cast of characters
a really interesting story and a lot of
great themes about justice
standing up for what's right and caring
about the people closest to you and
persona 5 royal which is the new version
that came out this year in 2020 adds so
much new content that
helps recontextualize the game in a lot
of ways and adds a lot of things you
really didn't know you needed but
make the experience a whole lot better
so easily the best part of persona 5
royal is the new third semester
with the new palace leader i was
actually able to empathize with a lot of
the things they were saying
where with the original persona 5 it's a
lot more black and white and good versus
evil
and the third semester is really really
great but beyond that there's so much
content in this 125 hour jrpg
and more specifically so much new
content in this 125 hour jrpg
that it's so hard to talk about
everything that's great with persona 5
royal in just one minute
so because of this news third semester
as well as the new characters the new
music the new area
those are the reasons that it makes
persona 5 royal a whole new experience
from the original persona 5 and it's why
it's one of gamespot's top 10 games of
2020.
shall we
[Music]
checkmate
y'all gotta look at the bigger picture
here nothing worth fighting for was ever
won without sacrifice
your fears your worries
your concerns take fifa and get out of
here
whatever your problem
i got you there are a whole lot of
reasons why i think final fantasy 7
remake
is one of the best games of 2020 but for
me the thing that really
makes it stick with me is that it
reminded me why
final fantasy vii is so iconic and why
people
herald it as the best game of all time
over time
i forgot what it is that final fantasy
really does well because
final fantasy kind of forgot it for a
while but with final fantasy 7 remake
realized what its strengths were again
and that is this idea of you as a player
going on a massive adventure with a
bunch of characters that you
start off not really knowing build an
intimate friendship with
to the point where when you finish the
game you feel like you're saying goodbye
to friends and it
really hurts and you long to be with
them again
and that's the core of final fantasy
that's what makes a great final fantasy
game
it reminded me why i love final fantasy
as a franchise and that's why i think
final fantasy 7
remake is one of the best games of 2020.
[Music]
our beloved planet is dying slowly
silently can you bear to see the planet
suffer
cloud
we're gonna make it home all of us
no exceptions
[Music]
please get up
what stands out the most about the last
of us part two is the incredible lanes
that naughty dog went
to dial up the stakes of the game the
action is thrilling
the stealth in the game is tense and the
set pieces had me at the edge of my seat
the gameplay is some of the most
immersive that i've seen and there was
never a dull moment with every encounter
whether it was from human enemy factions
or just
hordes of clickers chock full of
heart-pounding moments
the story has all the bones of a classic
western revenge tale with some twists
and turns
but it's these certain moments in the
game that kind of stand out almost like
their own vignettes
that are just some of the most beautiful
moments every dark pit in the story that
the game asks you to traverse
will be met with these beautiful pock
marks of light that just steep through
the cracks
and will stay with you for hours on end
and the perfect balance of bittersweet
in this game is just
masterfully crafted if there's one good
thing about this year
is that i had the pleasure of playing
the last of us part two and it's for all
of these reasons and more
this game is one of gamespot's best
games of 2020.
i don't know what happened she needed
her immunity
to mean something
maybe i just want to do right by her
[Music]
i swore to protect this island with my
life
but now the mongols have stolen our home
killed or some right
[Music]
he forgot what it's like to fight
someone stronger than you
go satsushima came in a year that open
world games seem to be coming by the
dozens but
what made tsushima unique was its
respect for the natural world and the
player's place within it
jin sakai is a samurai who struggles
with inner conflict between upholding
the tradition and protecting the people
and this element translates to the world
in a powerful and meaningful way
both through its story and through its
combat fluid stealth tactics and dynamic
samurai combat weave interchangeably
throughout the action and it's
satisfying and it's really deep
on top of that seeing the tributes to
classic samurai cinema is always a treat
to look at
with its gorgeous open world and its
refined combat goes to tsushima is no
doubt
gamespot's top 10 best games of this
[Music]
year
because i can't
[Music]
to call spirit pharah just a management
sim or just a 2d platformer would be
doing it a huge disservice because it is
so much more than that
the way that the game's gameplay and
storytelling intersect
make for a game that's unlike anything
i've played this year
so in spirit pharah you're not just
helping lost souls pass over to the
other side
you are getting to know these characters
you are forming bonds with them
and you're helping them with their
unfinished business
naturally there is the management side
of things you have a boat that you need
to upkeep
you have all its inhabitants that you
need to keep happy you can cook you can
farm
that's one part of the game it's
incredibly rewarding and satisfying
but the best bit is getting to know the
characters and building that
relationship
and then ultimately coming up against
the bittersweet moment where you need to
say goodbye
it's handled really beautifully honestly
if you have experienced any kind of loss
or you have anxiety around it
try spirit fairer because it's done in
such an incredible way that
i really can't recommend it more highly
that's why spirit fairer is one of
gamespot's best games
of 2020.
tales are told of hades whose very name
inspires fear and penitence i however
mean to tell you such a tale
listen carefully in hades every system
is built around either supporting or
delivering a satisfying narrative the
gameplay is fun the character designs
and voice acting are all
excellent the racially diverse take on
the greek pantheon
is a wonderful decision but it's the
stories that are the star
because they tie into haiti's biggest
strength
through storytelling it subverts the
idea of a game over hades is always
maintaining its forward momentum
with its stories a welcome innovation on
the traditional structure of a roguelike
this all results in a game with several
compelling reasons for seeing it all the
way through
despite the setbacks that you might
encounter and it's for those many
reasons that hades is one of our
favorite games of 2020.
in the yakuza business a dragon
symbolizes the top of the food chain
a fresh-faced fool like me can't just
casually rock a dragon
someday i want to earn my place and then
my dragonfish
is gonna shine even brighter than a
dragon dreaming big huh
[Music]
as much as we love kazuma kiryu it was
time to move on and that's okay because
yakuza like a dragon gives us kasuga
ichiban
a new lead and one of the best
characters in games now like a dragon
switches to a turn-based combat system
offering some strategic and challenging
battles it also paves the way for some
of the most hilarious moments in the
game
like a dragon captures that balance
between absurdist humor
and gripping drama that the series is
known for with various gangs and
organizations
all vying for power in various ways but
like dragon also shows growth in the
yakuza series
inseparable from its story are the
struggles of marginalized folks in the
context of japanese society
sex workers immigrants working class and
homeless people are all a part of this
journey too
the result is a jrpg that's very much
about adulthood
and the party dynamic isn't just for
turn-based battles it's part of
how ichiban grows where everyone is by
his side along the way
this game is very much about the power
of friendship and as always there's so
much captivating side content that fill
the streets
yakuza like a dragon gave long time fans
and newcomers
a wild and affecting experience and
that's why
it's one of gamespot's best games of
2020
well i guess a dragon fish is pretty
cool too
right i'm into it have you lost your
[Music]
[Applause]
nerve
demon souls is one of gamespot's best
games of 2020
because well of course it is one of the
most impressive
aspects of the game is how well it holds
up after 11 years
and after dozens upon dozens of
souls-like games have flooded the genre
a big part of this is thanks to
bluepoint's incredible recreation of
bulletaria
the graphical enhancements and expanded
art direction
is breathtaking bosses like the storm
king
are a sight to behold on the playstation
5. the window shaking shriek that the
behemoth lets out as it soars overhead
is an
auditory and visual spectacle and it's
something that couldn't be replicated
on last gen hardware but it's not just
all the fancy bells and whistles that
blue point added to demon souls that
makes it so special
that core foundation is so strong and
it's one of the reasons why we gave
demon souls our game of the year back in
2009 it's for these reasons and many
more that demon souls is one of
gamespot's best games of 2020.
still alive i am impressed
[Music]
so of all of these games we here at
gamespot have collectively decided that
the game of the year is
half-life alex from its astounding
quality and innovation half-life alex is
holistic and everything it sets out to
do from its pacing
gameplay writing horror comedy and yes
of course
it's astounding achievements in vr if
you're interested in hearing a more
in-depth conversation on why gamespot
thanks half-life alex at the game of the
year
you can check out a link in the
description below which is a
conversation between
jake decker michael hyam and me curt
[Music]
okay thank you so much for watching what
a year for
everything let alone gaming we hope you
had a good time we hope you're staying
safe and well
all right till next time see you later
[Music]
you